c'est merci de nous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de kiosques eu tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 4 mai
c'est un événement à l'échelle nationale
le musée de port royal des champs à
magny les hameaux rend hommage jusqu'au
29 juillet à rosa bonheur et sa famille
une première en france car la majorité
des oeuvres de la célèbre peintre
animalière du 19e siècle sont conservés
à londres le metropolitan de new york
frédéric franck directeur du musée des
impressionnismes de giverny nous
rejoindre en plateau dans quelques
instants nous aborderons la réouverture
du site et l'exposition accueillie par
le musée cette saison caillebotte
peintre et jardiniers jusqu'au 3 juillet
prochain l'art contemporain investit le
musée de la toile de jute jusqu'au 29
juillet le groupe de recherche acte de
la sorbonne asie en association avec le
cnrs
questionne la peinture en zone est
atteindre 12 artistes contemporains
propose une vingtaine de créations et on
démarre cette émission avec vous il
appelle bouder la varde bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes comédienne est
originaire de la vallée de chevreuse et
vous avez créé un spectacle pour
apprendre à gérer les conflits
on regarde tout de suite un extrait du
teaser de votre spectacle de goûter vous
avez peur de passer pour un rabat-joie
en imposant vos choix
de l'autre vous seriez vraiment frustré
si vous deviez vous inclinez c'est
sûrement que vous ignorez qu'il existe
des solutions créatives pour sortir des
conflits et pourquoi ne pas conjuguer
tout simplement les envies de chacun
on peut en même temps se divertir et
découvrir de nouveaux horizons
alors c'est un projet né de votre
expérience personnelle mêmes
professionnels d'ailleurs car vous
dirigez d'un veillance et performance un
cabinet de conseil et formation
spécialisée justement dans la question
des dans la gestion des conflits depuis
2008 alors vous avez eu cette idée
l'idée a germé il ya deux ans quand je
donner une conférence sur la gestion des
conflits dans les entreprises à
montparnasse et emilia santucci est venu
assister à cette conférence moi j'adore
ce qu'elle fait j'ai été très flatté que
à la fin du spectacle à vienne me voir
en la conférence c'est un lapsus ne peut
pas viennent me voir en me disant mais
là il ya tout pour faire un spectacle et
il m'en fallait pas de fallait pas me le
dire deux fois j'ai dit mon fait au fait
ça comment et on s'est mis à écrire
cette conférence a été entièrement
revisité et et c'est devenu un spectacle
alors donc le thème la gestion des
conflits mais quelles sont les questions
que vous abordez au travers de ce
spectacle alors c'est à la fois les
conflits dans la vie personnelle dans la
vie professionnelle et moi j'utilise mon
expérience de maman mon expérience des
pouces mon expérience de cadre dirigeant
et j'explique comment j'ai pris les
portes dans la gueule les pieds dans le
tapis
comment je m'en suis sorti ou pas et à
chaque fois les anecdotes que je ramène
sont des prétextes à exposer les prises
de conscience que j'ai eues dans chacune
des situations
est ce que vous proposez des solutions
qu'elle est le le format du spectacle
est ce qu'il s'agit d'un spectacle
didactique est ce que ça reste aux
conférences est ce qu'on est sur un one
man show
alors en fait c'est un peu tout ça je
suis seul en scène donc c'est un peu le
format one woman show dans le sens où il
y avait un caractère autobiographique
aux anecdotes qui sont ramenés je force
le trait sur mes enfants je france force
le trait sur mon chef mais finalement
tout ça s'est inspiré d'une histoire
vraie et ce à une vocation didactique
parce que même mon décor porte un
certain nombre de
concept j'ai cinq chaises et sur chacune
des chocs ce cinq chaises j'expose des
des concepts qui permettent de décoder
des enjeux dans des situations
difficiles ont fait justement regarder
tout de suite un extrait de votre
spectacle
l'ours polaire et moi on a pas de
conflit en ovale contact avec mes
enfants c'est maicon vous avez su law on
est dans contacts réguliers au 1
si je demande ce que je ne veux pas je
n'obtiens pas ce que je ne puisse qui a
pris un point tel qu'il est surnommé
gigi un petit peu coincé c'est la règle
numéro 1 et du coup à la sortie du
spectacle le public repart avec des clés
pour mieux gérer les conflits voilà
c'est ça alors tout le spectacle et est
ponctuée de prises de conscience avec un
geek est une sorte de running job de la
règle numéro 1 parce que si vous
connaissez pas la règle numéro 1 juste
folie dans le spectacle en fait il ya
douze règle numéro un et trois formules
magiques c'est des façons de regarder
les situations autrement pour pour
réussir à prendre du recul et à décoder
les enjeux et vous avez un retour direct
justement de votre public
alors là le commentaire le plus flatteur
que j'ai eus j'aime bien le reprendre
c'est une personne qui avait marqué
pendant mon crowdfunding ce spectacle
devrait être remboursé par la sécurité
sociale
parce que finalement au delà du fait que
les gens peuvent trouver des clés pour
se rendre la vie plus belle dans leur
quotidien c'est aussi un spectacle où on
peut prendre du plaisir à ceux à voir ce
qui se joue dans des situations tout
simple dans lesquelles on se reconnaît
en général donc vous menez justement vos
deux activités en parallèle et votre
activité professionnelle nourrit
toujours votre spectacle
les deux se nourrissent aujourd'hui je
continue à donner des formations sur la
gestion des conflits et c'est pas rare
que par demi journée j'ai introduisent
un petit sketch hilarant dit mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ce qu'elle fait là mais
en fait c'est vraiment une expérience
pédagogique dans laquelle il ya du fond
et tout ça s'est mis en forme avec une
direction artistique avec un décor avec
des
lumières et ça donne de la profondeur et
puis c'est fait pour parler au plus
grand nombre
le 14 mai prochain vous serez à
versailles donc là il s'agit d'une
représentation privée mais par contre le
2 juin vous serez à gif-sur-yvette à la
salle de la terrasse et là c'est une
représentation publique oui et c'est une
grande salle et et ça se replie très
très vite et je suis très contente
alors pour tous ceux justement qui
souhaiteraient s'inscrire vous pouvez
avoir plus d'informations à l'adresse
qui va s'afficher à l'écran de ce
spectacle en fait vous êtes dit pourquoi
ne pas se lancer dans une carrière de
one man show il ya beaucoup d'autres
univers qui nourrissent une envie
peut-être d'autres spectacles
alors assez vite je me suis rendu compte
que emilia et moi on avait écrit pour 4
euros on a monté une ride et donc cette
frustration elle va être compensé par un
deuxième spectacle dans l'univers à dos
donc il ya un spectacle qui va s'appeler
la dure vie de louise good luis est une
ado de 13 ans ses enfants ses parents
sont divorcés et elle voit elle voit les
situations difficiles d'une ado de 13
ans avec du harcèlement avec départ aux
chiens et ils la chance qu'elle a c'est
d'avoir dans l'environnement de son papa
qu'il ya un petit peu un coureur il
ramène un jour une nouvelle compagne qui
s'appelle isabelle et elle connaît
toutes les règles numéro un script qu'il
s'agit également d'une d'une histoire
inspirée de votre histoire personnelle
la wii tous mes enfants m'ont donné leur
bénédiction
mais ils savent que sa force un peu le
trait d'accord donc comme sale et la
susceptibilité n'est pas touché merci
isabelle godet la varde est revenu en
plateau d'avoir répondu à nos questions
donc votre représentation privée ce sera
le 14 mai à versailles mais la
représentation publique surtout que l'on
annonce ce sera le 12 juin à la salle de
la terrasse de gif sur yvette
plus d'informations et toutes les
inscriptions peuvent se faire à
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran et non
par la présence d'un autre yvelinois un
mur païen kris dane ou bruno masson de
son vrai nom vient de publier son
premier roman d'aventuré un livre écrit
en deux ans dans le train intitulé le
virtuose aux éditions le panthéon
l'histoire d'eric slater un voleur
chevronnés qui dérobent les plus beaux
bijoux dur
pour une agence philanthropiques
jusqu'au jour où une puissante
organisation se retrouve sur son chemin
ça se veut un livre facile à lire un
livre ce que j'appelle des romans de
plage comme je disais tout à l'heure et
qui emmène le lecteur dans une histoire
comme quand on va voir un film
d'aventuré on se pose pas finalement
beaucoup de question qu'on laisse laisse
embarquer dans dans l'action voilà et ça
se veut un livre d'action un livre
aventure dans lequel on se laisse
emmener les différentes personnes qui
m'ont accompagné dans la correction de
ce livre et qui sont plutôt littéraire
que romande aventure se sont laissés
accroché par l'histoire de ce livre et
je vous le disais jusqu'au 25 juillet
prochain le musée national de port royal
des champs à magny les hameaux rend
hommage à la célèbre peintre animalière
rosa bonheur et à sa famille
trois générations d'artistes ont pu
développer leur art dans l'atelier
maniwaki en 1865 par le frère auguste
pour y installer un atelier devenu
aujourd'hui annexe de la mairie
cette exposition est une première en
france car la plupart des oeuvres de
rosa bonheur sont conservés à londres ou
au metropolitan de new york
hommage à rosa bonheur il sa famille
durant plus de 50 ans ou dix neuvième
siècle
trois générations d'artistes dans la
famille ont développé leur art de la
peinture animalière à la musique dans la
maison des bonheurs de magny les hameaux
acquises en 1865 pour y installer un
atelier devenu aujourd'hui annexe de la
mairie
le musée de port royal des champs leur
consacre une exposition jusqu'au 25
juillet cette famille dans son ensemble
à plusieurs talents et donc l'idée était
de confronter ces différents médiums
artistiques de voir comment ces
différents médiums artistiques
finalement créer un art à partir d'
inspiration commune ce monde animalier
qui l'ont vraiment cherché à explorer
son toute cette forme 70 peintures et
sculptures sont exposées certaines de la
célèbre peintre animalière rosa bonheur
souvent comparée de son temps à jacques
raymond aubrac à ça d'autres de son père
raymond de son frère auguste et les
sculptures de son frère isidore un art
familiale tournée vers la nature et le
monde animalier avec une sensibilité
pour le monde des pâturages et de la
forêt un héritage du père de
rosa bonheur proche de la peinture
romantique ce qui est très intéressant
chez eux c'est que il y a eu un
véritable intérêt pour les spécificités
des animaux il ya vraiment la volonté de
s'intéresser très spécifiquement à la à
l'anatomie des animaux et avec ce côté
un peu positiviste du 19e siècle
si vous voulez et par ailleurs ils ont
pu participé à l'illustration d'ouvragé
scientifique agricole cette exposition
est une première en france
la majorité des oeuvres de rosa bonheur
se trouvant à londres où metropolitan à
new york pour la réaliser le musée de
port royal a bénéficié de prêts du musée
des beaux-arts de bordeaux du musée de
fontainebleau et de différentes
collections privées et après le musée de
port royal des champs nous allons nous
intéresser à un autre lieu culturel qui
n'est pas musée national mais qui en a
l'envergure tout du moins il s'agit du
musée des impressionnismes de giverny
nous en parlons avec vous frédéric
franck bonsoir vous êtes le directeur du
musée donc le musée vient de rouvrir
c'était le 25 mars pour une nouvelle
saison et c'est un musée qui est fermé
l'hiver quelles raisons à ça le musée
des impressionnismes giverny est un
musée tout jeune ça fait sept ans qu'il
existe sous cette forme là et c'est un
musée qui au début n'avait pas de
collection donc aujourd'hui pour faire
fonctionner un musée à l'année c'est
important d'avoir une collection
permanente ambitieuse est à ce jour le
musée en est dépourvu donc c'est vrai
qu'on fonctionne essentiellement sur les
expositions et une collection qui en
cours de constitution mais mais
effectivement on n'a pas la force de
frappe pour pour faire venir des
visiteurs ont pendant pendant l'hiver
l'autre chose c'est que le musée est
bien distinct de la maison et des
jardins de monet
mais en même temps il ya une
une forte envie quand on va au musée à
giverny de voir la maison et les jardins
de monet et inversement quand on vient
voir une exposition comme ça quand on
vient voir les jardins et la maison de
monet plus tôt on a envie de voir une
exposition aussi donc il y avait une
logique à ce que les deux fonctionnent
ensemble sur la même saisonnalité
jusqu'à novembre
ça permet également de profiter de la
floraison printanière ce qui ne gâche
rien vous l'avez dit cet ancien musée
quelle est la vocation de ces musiques
alors comme tout musée il cherche à
acquérir des oeuvres d'art à les étudier
à les conserver et les transmettre au
plus large public possible donc c'est un
lieu d'ouverture sur le monde et de et
de connaissances mais en même temps pour
connaissance avec un côté délectation le
plaisir de voir des belles oeuvres aussi
et en même temps il s'est amusé de
thématiques c'est pas le musée claude
monet justement c'est le musée des
impressionnismes alors c'est un
barbarisme qui signifie en fait que on a
cherché à ouvrir au maximum le sujet
c'est pour le coup c'est vraiment musée
d'ouverture on part de ce lieu qui est
universellement connu qui est giverny
que qui est connu à travers le monde
entier
elky qui attire les foules voilà pour
monnaie pour ses nymphéas et puis on
part de ce point de départ là et on
ouvre sur d'autres choses ce qui s'est
passé après l'impressionnisme parfois
les résonances dans l'art contemporain
donc ça nous permet de tirer un petit
peu le fil
et puis de proposer une programmation
assez vaste et ambitieuse l'or s'est
amusé qui est en développement quelles
sont les ambitions pour ce musée des
ambitions pour ce musée salle à terme
effectivement de constituer une
collection dit
de ce nombre s'est pas forcément facile
parce que dans ce qui concerne
l'impressionnisme c'est ce qui se fait
de plus cher par jeff koons ou picasso
voilà mais c'est aussi une ambition de
développement des publics c'est-à-dire
profiter de ce caractère universel très
populaire de la peinture impressionniste
pour pour proposer des petits pas de
côté des choses un peu plus pointu et
effectivement dans ce cas dans ce
contexte là il ya il ya des
développements à faire que ce soit sur
le plan du numérique que ce soit sur le
plan de d'ouvrir de nouveaux espaces
pour proposer des activités du musée
aujourd'hui il se doit de proposer des
choses à son public pour pouvoir
connaître mieux l'art c'est pas juste
exposer des oeuvres on a envie de faire
d'autres choses
on a envie d'être de jouer un rôle dans
la société et puis d'accueillir au mieux
les visiteurs alors avec un
agrandissement pourquoi pas peut-être
dans les prochaines années
donc vous l'avez dit on y parle de
monnaie mais pas que vous accueillez
chaque saison une exposition temporaire
et vous ouvrez cette saison avec une
exposition sur l'impressionnisme gustave
caillebotte que vous avez intitulé
peintre et jardiniers elle est présentée
jusqu'au 3 juillet prochain pourquoi est
ce que vous avez fait ce le choix de
cette impressionniste alors gustave
caillebotte c'est un artiste génial et
discret donc ce sont deux qualités qui
qui nous plaisent beaucoup de figurants
c'est mon frère figure du courant c'est
quelqu'un qui a qui a porté
sur sur ses propres données et sur sa
vie toute sa vie durant le mouvement
impressionniste c'est lui qui a fait
rentrer les principales oeuvres
impressionnistes qui sont aujourd'hui
sur les cimaises du musée d'orsay dans
les collections de l'état donc il s'est
battu pour pour l'impressionnisme et en
même temps justement parce que c'était
quelqu'un qui venait d'une famille très
riche et qui avait pas forcément besoin
de son art pour vivre il a très peu
cultivé sa postérité et il a eu une
reconnaissance très tardives c'est à
dire qu'en france on s'est intéressé à
lui essentiellement à partir de d'une
grande rétrospective au grand palais a
organisé par le musée d'orsay en 1994
mais avant ça on connaissait très peu et
puis il n'est pas toujours très bien
identifié parle par le grand public
alors il est célèbre pour ses évocations
du paris d'haussmann pour ça on connaît
bien mais c'est qu'elle c'est également
quelqu'un qui avait une passion pour
l'horticulture et laver un rapport à ces
trois avec les yvelines qui n'étaient
pas les yvelines avant oui c'est ça
c'est que gustave caillebotte
effectivement ce qui nous a fascinés
aussi c'est sa passion pour le jardinage
qui le rapproche de monnaie et ce jardin
il a cultivé à l'époque dans le
département de seine et oise qui était
un grand département qui couvrait
notamment des yvelines mais pas
seulement
à gennevilliers et caillebotte était
aussi un navigateur donc il a conçu et
construit ses propres bateaux il
descendait la scène donc on descend dans
la seine il a peint par exemple parme à
port-marly il a pu il est descendu à
carrières-sur-seine la lapin tout tout
cet univers entre entre argenteuil et la
mère a eu le havre donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a exploré toutes ses terres et qui
qui a fait de très belles oeuvres sur
ces paysages des yvelines et d'ailleurs
vous me disiez tout à l'heure combien il
était coûteux d'acquérir une toile
impressionniste est justement en ce
moment il ya un appel à la donation pour
acquérir le parterre de marguerite de
gustave caillebotte tout à fait le
musée a eu une opportunité en concevant
l'exposition caillebotte peintre et
jardiniers de faire l'acquisition d'une
toile de caillebotte
enfin en fait un ensemble de quatre
toiles qui est ce qui a pu être sauvée
d'un grand projet décoratifs de
caillebotte un parterre de marguerite
qui a beaucoup de résonance avec les
nymphéas de monet c'est pas les nymphéas
de monet mais il y a ça rappelle
furieusement certain nombre de principes
de cette peinture et donc on a décidé
pour sa de prendre sur nos propres fonds
mais aussi de proposer au public ce qui
se fait de plus en plus souvent dans les
musées 1 c c'est de participer et de
faire en une sorte de communauté c'est
pas juste
on ne fait pas juste un appel aux dons
pour faire un appel aux dons on pourrait
se débrouiller autrement mais le but
c'était aussi de fédérer autour de ce
projet et de est aussi toucher un public
plus jeune à travers une plateforme qui
est kiss kiss bang bang sur laquelle on
peut faire un don à partir de 5 euros
avoir le sentiment d'être propriétaire
un peu de l'oeuvre d'art
on a très bien merci frédéric franck et
d'être revenue en plateau d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et donc je
rappelle que le musée lui est ouvert
jusqu'au 6 novembre prochain et
l'exposition caillebotte peintre et
jardinier est présentée jusqu'au 3
juillet jusqu'au 15 mai
une autre exposition a retrouvé il
s'agit celle-ci de du grand rôle dans la
réinsertion professionnelle des mutilés
de guerre à rambouillet à la bergerie
nationale à l'occasion du centenaire de
la grande guerre cette exposition
retrace le quotidien de la population
rambo liten durant ses quatre années de
conflit elle permet aussi de présenter
l'école de rééducation de la bergerie
nationale qui entre 1916 et 10 921
former des soldats mutilés à un nouveau
métier leur permettant malgré leur
nouveau handicap de subvenir à leurs
besoins et de se réintégrer dans la
société et enfin également une dernière
exposition jusqu'au 29 juillet c'est
l'art contemporain qui investit le musée
de la toile de jouy le groupe de
recherche acte de la sorbonne en
association avec le cnrs questionne la
peinture peindre n'est ce pas atteindre
12 artistes contemporains propose une
vingtaine de créations avec l'idée d'une
peinture élargi andreu n'est ce pas
atteindre
la question est posée par le groupe de
recherche sur les arts de la sorbonne en
association avec le cnrs
pour y répondre il propose un cinquième
volet de la collection création et
patrimoine au musée de la toile de jouy
jusqu'au 29 juillet ce questionnement
entre peinture et tissage trouve sa
place au musée où l'étoile imprimés de
motifs dessinés par des artistes du
xviiie siècle ne sont pas des tableaux
la peinture s'est posée donc une touche
sur un support donc assez rester en
surface alors que la teinture s'est
imprégné diffusé dans un tissu dans une
toile et c'est donc c'est vrai que c'est
a priori très différents
cependant aujourd'hui et depuis les
années on va dire 60 les artistes
contemporains envisage une peinture très
élargie cyr qui dépasse le support bien
sûr peinture mais également qui
s'enfonce en profondeur d'autres
supports d'où l'idée de la teinture pour
l'exposition
douze artistes contemporains
s'approprient la peinture comme teinture
avec l'idée d'une peinture traversante
utilisent des toiles en chasser et des
tissus joue avec l'empreinte du soleil
ou encore travail l'encré sur papier ses
artistes à la fois même si les médiums
sont très différents sont très proches
il ya toujours un entêtement à
questionner la peinture encore et
toujours dire que la peinture c'est pas
seulement la représentation peindre
c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe par rapport
à un support qu'est ce qui se passe par
rapport aux dépôts de la peinture
elle-même sur ce support voilà dire
quand on travaille vraiment l'idée d'une
peinture élargi une peinture élargi un
passage entre le tableau peint et des
matériaux colorise assembler une
technique pour parvenir à un dispositif
réagissant dans l'espace à la manière
dont travail pictural et l'on poursuit
avec la rubrique cinéma tout de suite
vos réactions sur les nouveautés à la
fiche de ce mercredi
des dialogues sont formidables
c'est à la fois drôle c'est émouvant sa
délivre un message qui est évident sur
la différence c'est drôle qu'émouvant
non c'est bien c'est vraiment bien
c'était bien eux
c'était romantique voilà j'aime et qu'au
jeu l'état elle a chanté et c'était très
marrant et triste
alors je suis allé voir et 10 heures
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment un film frais
hyper agréable
en plus c'est hugh jackman donc c'est un
méfait parrainant fans et dense est
vraiment drôle j'ai passé un excellent
moment vraiment très bon septième art
toujours bertron pini du cinéma philippe
noiret des clés de ce mois nous donne
son coup de coeur alors le coup de coeur
du cinéma les yeux d'elsa cette semaine
c'est un film de john hillcoat
réalisateur australien qui on doit la
route ce proposition' des hommes sans
loi là il nous arrive avec un film de
gangsters dans le atlanta d'aujourd'hui
un film très moderne très très dans le
réel d'aujourd'hui est un film qu'on
compare au heat de michael mann qui est
quand même probablement le must de ce
qu'on a pu faire en film de braquage
alors ce film nous raconte l'histoire de
deux groupes plus ou moins entre mêlée
un groupe de braqueurs un groupe de
flics les flics ont introduit une taupe
chez les braqueurs mais en même temps
les braqueurs ont aussi des taupes chez
les flics
donc il ya comme ça une sorte de mélange
entre entre ces deux groupes
là forcément très simple à comprendre
mais en tout cas on entre comme ça dans
une dans une aventure absolument folle
qui dure deux heures qui s'arrête
absolument jamais on a affaire à casey
affleck un jeune type plein de promesses
woody harrelson un vieux type toujours
plein de promesses à kate winslet qui
est une très très grande actrice et à
geel cadeau qu'on a vu récemment dans le
rôle de wonder woman
ton boulot être plus monstrueux
le monstre
et rentrer à la maison la fin de l'année
aucune limite à ce qu'un homme désespéré
peut faire quand il est piégé
je filme on le présente ici ce week end
en version française samedi à 18h15 en
version originale dimanche à 20h30 à des
tarifs toujours aussi accessible
j'espère que vous auriez la curiosité de
venir voir ce petit chef-d'oeuvre
à bientôt dans nos salles et avant de
nous quitter voici quelques dates pour
un week-end culturel vendredi 6 mai
20h30 à la batterie de guyancourt
retrouver laillé gros avec son chant
doté d'un côté frais et spontané qui
traverse la cumbia contemporaine et avec
la tradition folklorique d'un côté et
des beats ravageurs de l'autre
et un festival de métal sur saint
quentin en yvelines ce week-end vendredi
6 mai 20h au café de la plage de
maurepas et samedi 7 mai à partir de 18h
à la salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux c'est la première
édition du festival métal of open ce
faire organisé par meta sauce sur ces
deux dates 9 groupe représenteront un
métal ouvert et éclectique
moi
la corde
et enfin au prisme d'elancourt mardi 10
mai 20h30
la chorégraphe et danseuse nacera belaza
vous présente le cri créé en 2008 le cri
est devenu une pièce essentielle de la
danse d'aujourd'hui
et c'est déjà la fin de votre émission
culturelle vous pourrez la voir et la
revoir sur notre site internet
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée